elle est belle de promo aux États-Unis
reste souvent des événements sexistes
puisque la tradition veut que les filles
ne choisissent pas elles-mêmes leurs
cavaliers mais que ce soit toujours le
garçon qui choisissent et invite la
personne de son choix à être sa
cavalière
ce soir
pour lutter contre cette tradition
moi-même guillaume Bats à être mon
cavalier
enfin de montrer au monde la souffrance
que peut subir une fille qui va au bal
avec un partenaire non désiré
quoi non désiré mais tu vas quasiment
supplier pour que je vienne ça veut pas
dire que c'est désiré Guillaume c'est un
acte de résistance comme une grève de la
faim ou une automutilation
que tout le monde voit que tu voulais
pas que je vienne c'était mécanismes
psychologiques et c'est pour secouer les
consciences
déjà rien que le fait de te voir à la
télé ça se trouve vachement